[Music]
welcome back to the data science hangout
hope everyone's having a great week
if you're joining for the first time
welcome it's great to meet you i'm
rachel dempsey and i'm the host of this
hangout
basically what it is it's an open space
for the whole data science community to
connect and chat about data science
leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science
if you ever want to go back and re-watch
prior sessions
or share with someone who's missed it
we do have a brand new data science
hangout site i think i can still call
this new
for a few more weeks but rob can share
that in the zoom chat right now as well
we really want this to be a space where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone so there's three ways
you can ask questions
you can jump in live raise your hand on
zoom might be the best way with a bigger
group
you can put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to put a little star after
your question too if you want me to read
it maybe you're in like a coffee shop or
something and then we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously too and we'll share that in
the chat window as well
we really love the dialogue that happens
live during these hangouts
and so if you do find yourself inspired
and maybe you have spoken a few times
maybe consider holding back a bit for
others to jump into because we want this
to be as inclusive as possible and
making room for others is also an
important part of that
but again just want to reiterate that we
love to hear from everyone no matter
your level of experience or area of work
but with that i'm so happy to be joined
by my co-host for today katie schaefer
and katie i'd love to turn it over you
to just introduce yourself and maybe
share a bit about the work that you do
on your team
yeah absolutely well hi guys it's great
to be here um i don't know if anybody
else is in the midwest region but heavy
storm here so hopefully you guys are all
staying warm if you are
um so my name's katie schaefer i work at
a company called beam dental so we're an
insurance company and we focus on
ancillary benefits uh some work that we
do on our team so i oversee the data
science and the analytics team and this
was kind of my first big focus on an
analytics team so it's been really fun
to kind of see the differences and skill
sets and focuses between the two teams
and we do a huge variety of things
across the two teams so on the data
science front
most of what we do is kind of the more
traditional predictive modeling problems
getting those into production and most
of those are business facing um so we do
pair with our underwriting and actuarial
team but they own kind of those
traditional actuarial models and we
handle a lot of the business facing data
science problems on the analytics team
um we do all sorts of things so
a lot of analyses but also a lot of what
i like to call data consulting so folks
from the business coming to us with key
problems that can be answered or
illuminated with data and us working to
try to provide them some additional
information some opportunities for
process improvement
and from a tool tool stack perspective
our python
python is pretty big on the data science
team
and also looker we recently moved over
to looker which is exciting from tableau
so
lots of sql too
nice so i know there'll be a lot of
questions coming in but to kind of open
up the discussion i know
in the hiring panel that you were part
of i'm hiring great data science teams
we talked a bit about the involvement of
in the open source community and how
that impacts higher ability
and i think it'd be interesting to just
kind of dive deeper into your
perspective on on that too
yeah
um so i can just give kind of a general
overview and then
excited to kind of dialogue from there
so
um i think it um is kind of rarer than i
might have expected that i see some
heavy involvement in the open source
community on applicants so when i do i
get pretty excited um for a few reasons
so i think from my perspective it shows
a true kind of self-driven desire for
learning for improvement
um and for kind of staying fresh on all
the tools within the industry and latest
packages etc um so it speaks to that
kind of genuine interest in the job
you're applying for versus um versus
just kind of a nine to five that
somebody's focused on in my perspective
i think some kind of watch outs there is
obviously there's a huge range of
involvement in open source communities
so i think really what's super rich is
when i can dialogue with somebody and
hear how amazing their experience has
been in that open source community and
that data science community
because that to me really speaks to kind
of their passion for the topic and the
job at hand
so that's kind of a high level how i
like to think of it um it's always a
nice uh a nice thing to see and i love
to kind of learn more about it
awesome yeah i'm sure there'll be some
follow-up questions on that too and it'd
be great to chat more about it but also
maybe to help us all think like put
ourselves into the mindset of the work
that you do it'd be great to understand
like what are a few
like questions your
data science team is solving your
business problems that you're helping
solve as well yeah so um
from a data science perspective uh at a
kind of super high level one problem
that comes across multiple different
domains of our business would be kind of
at a high level entity matching so
um you can think of this is a common
problem in any business right but when
individual entity comes in you've got
kind of name and address how do you pair
it with the names and addresses in your
system appropriately and at scale
so that kind of hits a few different
places that beam whether it be new
business and leads or more on the kind
of the claims aspect of things um so
that's kind of one current project that
should give you a bit of a sample and
then also kind of on the business facing
front um always an appetite for knowing
information sooner than it's available
so if you think of an opportunity coming
in
knowing how much that opportunity is
going to end up at from a dollar
perspective knowing which opportunities
were more likely to win or which clients
uh you know kind of have the optimal
potential from a cross-seller upsell
standpoint so some kind of really
general business problems um in the
insurance space um so that's kind of a
high-level overview of from a data
science side i think some of the things
that are top of mind now yeah
cool and when you say like win those
opportunities um what does that actually
mean for for being dental
yeah so for bean we sell insurance um
and so we sell uh as any kind of health
care insurance typically works usually
we work with brokers who work at
brokerages so it's kind of a b to b to c
space so we're it's not like a car
insurance company where you sell
directly to the consumer um so there is
kind of a sense of how can we prioritize
the service for you know our swath of
brokerages we work with
um so probably similar in kind of a
direct to consumer space uh you know who
do i send my really high touch marketing
to who do i spend a lot of time doing
outreach to um
yeah
okay thank you that's super helpful yeah
i see there was an anonymous question
that came in on slido um
about talking about open source so when
you you think about that how does stack
overflow fit into that
um so i am maybe a bad example of a
stack of open uh stack overflow
contributor so i am very much a consumer
of stack overflow i'm a little
intimidated to post my own questions
um but i think stack overflow is hugely
kind of um obviously it's impactful i'm
sure every single person on this call
has used stack overflow a
lot of quite a bit um i have never come
across somebody who was a big stack
overflow contributor from an
interviewing perspective
but that would be amazing if i did i
think
actually one of my co-workers
father is one of the great contributors
to stack overflow and our forums
so i know i was just super excited to
talk to him uh and
to me that's just the the highest honor
in terms of contribution to the open
source community in my opinion is really
contributing to stack overflow questions
reproducible examples but then the
answers uh as well awesome i see tatiana
in the the chat you had a great question
there and i'd i'd love to have you ask
that live too
sure i was about to type in i'm sorry
yeah of course it's more of a
philosophical question to get us started
um i imagine you have one team obviously
uh but
since you do present yourself as a
director of analytics and data science i
would be curious to hear about how do
you
think about the differences between the
two and i see that initially you were a
manager of advanced analytics and then
data science was kind of like join
afterwards does it mean that you um
started undertaking more forecasting and
predictive analysis and how do you think
about it and if you have um the split
and responsibilities in your team
members who are responsible one for you
know advanced analytics and one for data
science and how you can comment on that
yeah that's a great question um so i
think the delineation of data science
and analytics looks probably a little
different at every business so i'll just
caveat it with my answers not
the right one in my opinion it's just
kind of how i think about it um so data
science and analytics are two different
but really related teams so they work
together quite collaboratively
um so
we have shared lab meetings shared team
meetings for now
i think as teams grow in size obviously
that can be harder to keep that cohesion
together we also really work extremely
closely with data management now so we
have you know same stand-ups um i could
see in the future there be kind of uh
from a just like functional perspective
delineations of that from a meeting
perspective
but i think it's really important to
keep that bridge together in terms of
how i think of the differences between
analytics and data science so first
thing that comes to mind is from a tool
stack perspective
traditionally i think the analysts are
much heavier on the sql skills much
heavier on bi skills so
um a traditional analyst that i'm
typically interviewing or hiring um is
much more likely to have experience with
like tableau or looker versus a shiny
shiny for example typically when i start
to see example with something like shiny
i also see really strong programming in
r python and then often it tends to kind
of correlate with the deeper statistics
background
um
so that's from a tooling perspective
some delineation so our data science
team definitely more focused on python
and r versus traditional
bi platforms
sql really common amongst both of the
teams but it's pretty strong among our
analysts
from a skill set perspective in terms of
functional problems how i like to
describe it is
i view the analyst as kind of the
business data consultant so they are
often tackling kind of vague questions
so it might be a trend that's being
observed in the business and their task
is to kind of dig in from a data
perspective and find
indicators that might be um indicative
of why that trend is occurring and also
maybe
qualitatively or i should say kind of
from a trend perspective indicative of
what might happen in the future but they
might actually not get to the level of
building the predictive model to make
that happen it's more kind of
extrapolation from visual trends often
and some basic kind of descriptive
statistics um and then a heavy amount of
like data storytelling which i know can
be a general term but i do think it's a
core aspect of what they do
um and then also just bread and butter
bread and butter reporting so how are we
doing as a business on our key metrics
right so you know wins you know our deal
sizes etc just the staple
daily refreshing tracking of that
data scientists often they will
be working on a very specific problem
that was uncovered from the analysts so
usually a predictive model
there are definitely some automation
projects that are using tools like
python but in my mind kind of more
traditional automation work
um
so if you could imagine something like
extracting information from pdfs right
requires kind of a data science skill
set might be a probabilistic model
underneath that but could also just be
solved with some kind of classic tools
and then you know from the end user's
perspective you are automating their
workflow right um even though it is in
essence programming um so data science
more specific focused problems less
stakeholder facing time more development
time predictive modeling problems and
automation analysts really partners to
the business and those data consultants
so hopefully that helped that's just how
how i have the view i have shaped but
could be much different other places
that's fantastic thank you
yeah
thanks katie
mark i see you had a great question in
the chat too if you want to jump in
yeah sure sorry i was on mute um yeah uh
katie you mentioned you have
um
your data scientists you know on the
team use both python and r i guess like
how do you manage that
um you know mix of languages within the
team
that's a good question so um admittedly
i am the person who is our user and our
two kind of core data scientists are
python users um so
i'd say the vast majority of the
development code and production code is
in python
in terms of how we manage it though i
think it seems simpler in practice than
i pictured it to be so both of the data
scientists are really strong in python
and have dabbled in r at least
if not used it in a master's program etc
so they can read r and i can read python
and vice versa but if either one of us
were going to build something it would
be much quicker to do it in our
preferred language um i am kind of a
proponent of the right tool for the job
so
most of these things we have not tackled
quite yet but are on our roadmap there
are certainly problems that i foresee
are being the better tool because
there's a more robust set of statistical
packages out there for kind of niche
problems
um so
i'm a big proponent of right tool for
the job right tool for you
but i'd say um
anyone who's fairly strong in one
typically doesn't have problems reading
the other or interpreting the other so i
will often do
code reviews or coaching sessions on
python code even though i'm not the
expert in python it's pretty quick for
us to get on the same page of what i'm
trying to convey or what they're trying
to convey um and conceptually most of
our like working sessions are going to
be more about the model we're choosing
the you know performance metrics etc
features that we want to include and a
little bit less about the specifics of
code so if you're hiring kind of really
new novice talent yes absolutely i do
think it's critical that you're really
strong in the language you want to train
them on or somebody who's senior on your
team is
that would be a problem um but since we
kind of started out with some more
senior folks they are pretty savvy in
one or the other but they do have a
preference
thank you
yeah thanks thanks katie kind of
following up on that i see robert had
asked the question
as well that was how do you think
through which tool is the right one for
the project or requirement
and i think that might go even into like
when you talked about the data analyst
side of the house using looker for
example too
that's a good question we actually have
kind of an example i'm thinking of right
now where i'm trying to
guide kind of our senior data analyst
and our data scientist and which tool to
use um so i usually start with the like
end user of whatever we're outputting so
i mean if it's a model it's kind of a
no-brainer like looker the bi tool sql
probably not the right tool set um so
for more of those problems where it's
kind of automation or the model is being
used as an input somewhere that may be
more facing and less of like a number
where
things are being calculated off that's
when i feel like that decision comes
into play um so right now we have a bit
of an automation project basically at a
high level just automated reports that
need to get churned out every month with
a heavy amount of math and calculations
under the hood
um so right now i'm trying to evaluate
for the end users of this what are they
primarily what are their primary needs
do we need this to be static auditable
and traceable
that might lend more to python or our
markdown right as the tool set um or do
they need to interact with elements of
this and there's less of that need for
it to be a static pdf
that might put me more in the looker
camp right so there are aspects of it
where they want to kind of see how
they're doing internally for our sales
team monthly um where the just the
static value could work but they also
kind of want the ability to like input
new values and see how those change or
how much basically something would be
worth to them when they're kind of
prospecting it um so without going into
too much detail that kind of brings me
down the path of like wait a second what
tools are really required to meet that
that end user need so i usually start
with the end user and then back up from
there and that's kind of the same
process the team goes through
i like that a lot starting with the end
user
yeah jill i see your question you said
was answered with that as well um but i
think it brings up a point to me to
think about
like you have the data analysts and data
scientists as well and they're using
different tools but do you sometimes
have people moving from one side to the
other like data analysts starting to use
r and python and then
absolutely yes so we um we definitely
have analysts who are more senior ones
who are fairly strong in python um but
they are
they're definitely stronger in the bi
tools and sql um so there are examples
in the past before we had them our built
up data science team where they were
doing some of that automation work and
they were doing some like api calls for
you know automated sends of market
marketing material for example um but
definitely
i try to think of like where is their
skill set strongest and it's going to
take them longer to figure out how to do
something in python than it will if they
just are using the tools that they use
every single day so now that we have
that capability those sorts of problems
are probably no longer going to them but
they can interface with that
um
i would say from
an
uh from a data munching perspective it
has been super illuminating to work with
like a pretty advanced analytics team to
see how many how much they do in sql in
terms of data manipulation it is it is
pretty impressive um being more of an r
user i
honestly you know wouldn't think of that
as my first choice for things like
pivoting et cetera um but they are
pretty strong in sql so they will often
use that that being said there are there
are some of them who prefer to do that
sort of thing in like python so they'll
just kind of query the database do their
data manipulation there and then kind of
write back if they need
to okay thank you
yeah i'm just scrolling through to see
which other questions we didn't get to
yet and zach i see you had a question um
in the chat too would you want to jump
in and add some context on that one yeah
you mainly answer
ask my question rachel but uh yeah just
a case of
i was more like it also goes into the
internal politics the
are the data science people
seen as on the same level as their
analysts or those data science being
seen as above
uh just like cr
we also
well career and training because we
quite often talk about like training
uh and how to upskill people as
given that you have you used liquor and
shiny
try and promote promote people to use
shiny instead
and upskill themselves
and then
maybe move to become a data scientist or
is it just a
you you specialize in this that's what
you're best at use this
but again you mainly answer the question
um
good there's a good question on looker
and shiny though so to clarify nobody
today at least in my current company is
using shiny that was more of my
experience so i was trying to say like
bi to me was shiny kind of before i was
more exposed to the analytic side
um so that would absolutely be kind of
an interesting inter-company trade-off
if people were using i feel like i've
talked to people at companies who had
like mode shiny
tableau like multiple different ones
right so that is kind of an interesting
question on like
who wins where do the resources go do
you focus on moving people too shiny if
they are using looker um
i'd say the way i would personally think
about it is
what is the quickest
on the analytic side what would be the
most efficient path for getting the
business what they need
and if my analysts aren't super strong
and shiny that probably is not to be
honest the tool we're going to use
versus my data scientists right like if
they um
so right now obviously their main tool
is python um but i would never
ask them to learn looker if they are
comfortable building a web app in python
like that wouldn't make any sense
um and the same with an r user so i
think definitely on kind of our growing
product analytics side um that
seems like it kind of draws more of an r
crowd um so i could absolutely see them
doing things like churning out a shiny
dashboard and i think um the
organization is at a size in which we're
kind of serving different pockets of the
org
so while you don't want to kind of
increase technical debt i do think it's
possible that like a certain group of
end users might have more of an
inclination to kind of the look and end
feel of shiny versus looker um and so i
would never have somebody kind of move
over to a tool they're uncomfortable
with unless there was a good reason for
them to do that
okay yeah sorry but you would try and
help promote like so you would just say
this do what's most comfortable rather
than saying we would like you to
eventually move to shiny for example
um unless there's a clear business need
to then yeah absolutely i would not just
stick with what's comfortable right so i
guess uh different than r but tableau
and look are good examples of that right
like most people we'd hire most people
on the team are more comfortable in
tableau but from a use case perspective
the customizability of looker just
seemed like the way we needed to go from
a business for a lot of the use cases we
have um so
while tableau is the comfortable choice
we're still going to transition over to
looker
and i would hope the talent that we have
is always going to be on on board for
learning something new so
okay yeah thank you so i don't know
either in tableau and look how much so i
was trying to use examples oh no worries
yeah
thanks katie i
i saw i think maybe on linkedin
at some point that you were hiring for
data science roles a few months back and
was just curious to dive deeper into
like that topic of hiring too and like
what are particular things that you look
for in hiring on your own team
yeah so from a data science perspective
i mean the
bread and butter staples are that you
can program um and i do kind of
primarily only focus on r python so
um while he would absolutely consider a
candidate who was really strong in sas
and maybe had never used our python
i just feel like the talent pool there's
just it's just already so rich in one or
the other that i would not really
unless there was something else really
shining about that application i would
definitely favor somebody who has those
skills in our python in terms of which
one or the other um i'm kind of agnostic
and that might be because i come from
being more of an r user uh but i think
it's just hard enough to find good
people i think trying to put that added
layer of like you have to be strong in r
or python is way too restrictive um so i
think the other thing just based on
where we are as a business is
the data scientist candidates i was
looking for definitely needed some kind
of element of not just developing the
model but also scoping it delivering it
back to the business
um so we certainly lean heavily on
myself and the analytics team for that
portion of things but it was also also
important to me that the candidate was
kind of senior enough to have that
exposure
and hopefully
yeah that's helpful too i'm just
thinking more about like how you found
found candidates as well because i know
like a lot of people have
been sharing job postings and saying
it's difficult hiring right now um
and where yeah where do you
generally find candidates
yeah i mean to be honest it took a while
right i mean maybe it's the planning
fallacy but i
thought it would take a while and it
took longer um in terms of where we
found them so one ended up being a
referral of the other um which is kind
of the best situation um but i believe
kind of it was just linkedin seeing the
job posting but i absolutely got some
great candidates who just ended up not
being a fit for a variety of reasons
through open source
community forums so i posted on our
ladies i posted on kind of our local
columbus tech
tech org channel and i definitely talk
to amazing people from those sources um
so that's kind of always a first go-to
for me is yes our recruiter puts it on
linkedin but then i take that link and i
push that out to all the open source
communities that i'm involved in so
awesome thank you
edgar i see you had your hand raised do
you want to jump in
yeah so i have a question so
when you're looking at candidates and
there someone's looking to transition
from one industry into another how do
you take that into account when they may
not have the most relevant experience in
the industry that they're in
yeah
um
there are trying to think of like of our
whole team there's probably only one per
one or two people who had insurance
experience um
obviously i
favor that if you had insurance
experience but again i just find that
it's
pretty hard to find really good people
who fit your specific needs and the time
you're at in an organization so there
are a ton of amazing data scientist
candidates out there but starting out
fresh it wasn't really the best play for
me to think of somebody super junior
because they were just there wasn't
enough like coaching time to go around
right so i know that can be a mixed
message because you might be thinking
like there's tons of great candidates
out there totally are but i think when
you're in kind of an early to mid stage
growth company your role requirements
get a little more narrow and it's just
can be hard to find really good people
um
so
i um
hopefully that kind of answered your
question um is there any kind of
portions i didn't address from that i
think it's yeah i think also kind of
making yourself competitive i think in
that terms and you did answer that to a
degree but i think
like i'm transitioning from education
into like a different industry and so
you know how do you
get past that initial where a recruiter
might say
how can i make these connections from
one industry to another and i think
that's a great question so um so like i
said we definitely have hired people
without insurance backgrounds but i
think what has made them really
attractive is they have some sort of
demonstrated ability to learn right and
showing a passion for that right so
i can teach you the industry it's much
harder for me to teach you like
foundational statistics principles to
teach you coding and programming so
that's always my approach but i will say
what can be a little challenging is if
you ask somebody for examples of when
they taught themselves a new concept or
learned a new process in the past and
they come up blank that can be kind of a
red flag for like like will they pick up
on the business aspect of this as
quickly um i know coming out of academia
myself that can be a tough transition
because you in reality if you've got a
phd right like you have four to five
years of job experience but people don't
often look at you that way in the market
unfortunately and i think that's a big
miss
um
unfortunately there i think a lot of
that is uh
you just getting the opportunity to sell
yourself right so like if you can just
get that first interview and demonstrate
how
um how the skills you learn in your
academic position will translate and i
mean what a better example of like grit
than completing a phd right like if you
can sell yourself on the transition of
your skills
i think you can succeed in that
interview process but i think where
people probably unfortunately get
overlooked is just getting that first
interview
um so i think a lot of that if you're
coming straight from academia is like
tailoring your interest to the right
company so
this is just a generalization i wouldn't
say this is true of every major company
absolutely not i've definitely seen
large companies that have a
appreciation for academic talent um but
in general i think startups or mid like
mid-stage growth companies tend to be a
little bit more friendly to the academic
crowd because there are folks there i
think if you can find a manager that you
might be working under who has their phd
they are going to be more alert to you
as a as a high talent potential so our
recruiters for example they are the
first stop but i am looking in there all
the time at people coming in and i will
tell them hey just because this is a
senior role don't rule somebody out just
because they have a phd in no work
experience i want to see them um but if
you don't have the hiring manager doing
that then you might get overlooked and
you might not even get that first
conversation
thank you
thank you
and actually like elaborating on that a
little bit i can see that tatiana asks a
great question um if you want to jump in
tatiana about how katie went from one
uh
area to another moving into analytics
yeah that was very interesting and i i
recently interviewed for um actually i
was interviewed for how i shifted my
careers and one of the aspects that i
highlighted was self-promotion
especially we as i don't want to like
generalize or miss everybody out but as
women we tend to undersell ourselves i
feel like and it's very important not to
like get all that mental
uh self-talk out of the picture and just
go ahead and tell yourself because if
you don't if you don't speak up and if
you don't know how to promote your
persona how to think through the eyes of
the person who is hiring you meaning so
you can showcase how your analytical
thinking that you developed during your
phd or your master's or whatever how it
translated into your business case is
very important and then you can do
projects on the side that actually show
that here's an example of how i did it
because nobody prevents you from doing
courses on the side and do projects on
the side but this is my tension and the
question was um if you could speak more
about your personal experience how you
transition from psychology to analytics
and data science
yeah so um so i was in a phd program and
they can vary but um mine started in
clinical psych so the there's a heavy
focus on research so ohio state's a
pretty big research institution so what
was clinical psych and so technically a
part of it is
getting your license as a clinician and
seeing clients um that was not the
intent of my program so like my
professor hired me because he he chose
me because he wanted me to work on
academic research with him so that was a
heavy amount and training of statistics
statistics courses experimental methods
and then programming as well um so that
alone though especially in today's
market would have been
a bit hard to sell as a transition um
and i feel like what you need to like
focus on is that one that first
opportunity that's transitional that's
the bridge i think you can get it from
user groups and that's another huge
value of the open source community um
for me it was a kind of graduate
assistant social association with
nationwide insurance so they basically
bought
you know kind of fledgling phds out of
their teaching contract which they
didn't want to do anyways um and they
you know would pay them to work in their
analytics department so it was a great
gig for me and it was that like first
exposure and then once i had that like
my network opened up i had quote unquote
industry experience even though it was
light
and the path was just open from there
for me to fly on um i think with masters
of analytics and data science programs
today it's like a little i think some of
these core phd and master's programs
um can get overlooked and i think the
way to sell yourself is to one just
learn to sell yourself which is a very
foreign concept in academia but two also
to
to get that first experience and i think
if it's hard to find user groups are a
great way to start open source
communities are an exceptional way to
start because you will
at the very least dialogue and meet
people who can expose you to that first
industry opportunity that's more formal
than the um than the like just user
group itself i will also say there's a
few programs so i'll throw one in the
chat um that i am like volunteer at so
one is called the erdos institute it was
founded by math phds and their whole
purpose is to train phds who have
decided academia is not for them to get
that industry experience so it's kind of
like a boot camp but the talent is just
incredible there um
and also the training and prep for
industry so that's kind of another like
segway example but like you kind of just
need to find that first connection i
think and that's the hardest hardest
part
that would be great if you could share
those links after katie i guess i can
share them on on linkedin too
cool but um
kind of following up on on this topic
too there was an anonymous question sent
to me um that are was what are the
skills that you look for in entry in an
entry-level data scientist from someone
who's
has a degree in operations research and
financial engineering but is having a
difficult time
landing a job
and would love to just hear more about
like what tips you have for selling
like yourself and getting that role too
yeah
um so entry level i'd say
the thing that i would look for is um
i guess it's all basic and i'm probably
talking all relative and i'm talking to
some probably fairly advanced r users
but at least like that basic
foundational skill set so we have a
take-home project as part of our
interview process um also i think you're
just asking questions as an interview
you can tell how deep their skill set
goes but from a basic level i would hope
they could do the bulk of the analyses
in either r python but it might not be
as well set up as somebody who i might
interview for like more of a
intermediate or senior role so
instead of you know using functions and
not repeating yourself it might just be
getting the job done um and if the role
is really entry level that might be okay
right like that might just show that
they have the potential to grow um
so i'd say that's one is like kind of
just assessing where their code is at
and just knowing that they can code but
it probably needs some work right like
they have room to grow
um
i'd say probably more important to me is
their ability to like
prioritize and take
take things into their own hands and
take on work independently with some
guidance right so some demonstrated
experience of having done that in the
past is super important i think for any
level honestly to give you the comfort
that you know they can grow into more of
that intermediate senior position
thanks kitty and
yeah on this topic of hiring too if
other people are like
have had challenges with this or are
hiring for roles feel free to put those
into the chat or jump in to the
conversation too
one of the
anonymous questions that
came up which it was a follow-up from a
previous question that i can't figure
out which one it was but it was what do
you mean by incurring technical debt
um
so i mean i'd say at the highest level
it's just having a bunch of legacy
systems that very few or no users are
using um but maybe still contain
important pieces of the business
um so that would be like the highest
level version what i'm kind of referring
to specifically is
i mean there's probably like an optimal
point where you want to cut off
expanding the tools like i personally
would not want to run a team from like a
bi perspective where people were using
tableau looker mode shiny like that's a
lot of tools do you really need that
many tools to get the job done oh and by
the way shiny is the only free one on
that list right so now we're just
spending money um
but i'd say more importantly from a data
science perspective is r and python seem
like close knit communities i do think
if you're intermediate to strong in one
you can at least read and connect on the
other and if not contribute from a
development perspective
oh i think somebody might have gone off
mute
uh so but i think what would be
challenging is like if we had somebody
we hired using sas or like matlab
i would have less certainty that other
people could pick up their work if that
person were to leave
um you know just in general right if
their work needed a contributor to help
with it on
that to me is like maybe i guess the
most important aspect of not expanding
too wide on the tooling perspective is
like can your work be re
used by others picked up improved on
while you're here or while you're gone
right and so i think the wider your tool
swath gets the more of a risk that
becomes
awesome thank you
yeah
um
guillerme and sorry if i pronounced your
name incorrectly i see you put a
question to the chat too if you want to
jump in
oh hello uh i'm coming from a mechanical
engineering field
so mostly we have to develop new project
products or improve already existing
ones
and
because of this
my work comes to gather data initially
and later i come to the engineering
field and work
but my problem is
i create these projects i
develop them but because of no
disclosure agreements i can
really share my work my data analysis
so i get a lot of work but exclusive is
freelancer because as i can't show
my projects i can't really get a job
easily
so what could you guys recommend for me
like what could i do
because i have a lot of personal
projects and it's not seeming like it's
something that's going to
improve as soon as i wanted
if you could give me a response on that
it would be great
yeah i was reading zach's answer i love
that like is it possible to
simulate
something akin to some of the data you
would use and then feature that as a
work sample
um i would be curious i do feel like
project portfolios
submitting the actual work is not really
something i've seen it on
in interviews um so like you need to be
able to discuss the work which might be
part of your problem i'll try to address
that in a second um i've seen less often
that you need to actually submit your
prior work um outside of like a work
sample they'll give you as part of the
interview process um so i would be kind
of curious as to like how often you've
account encountered that but yeah i
really liked zach's answer and like
simulating data i would say if more of
the challenges what i think it might be
in just simply describing the projects
um i mean that's really tough right like
even when you guys ask me about the beam
projects right you want to
say something meaningful but you don't
want to be too specific um so i think
honestly there's probably more
help than you realize in like
honestly having kind of a role play
conversation with yourself
on a questions you're getting in an
interview and practicing answers that
are more generalized and abstracted so i
would take one of your specific problems
and this is also a good tip for academia
right like my academic research nobody
really cares about process outcome
therapy like research right like that's
not going to translate well so i need to
translate that to like an abstract
problem that i tackled with statistics
and programming
um and i i wonder if there's a piece of
what you could do the same here so like
i don't know your specific problems i
would fumble over even trying to guess
um but trying to figure out like
what am i doing in an abstract sense am
i classifying things am i doing an
unsupervised approach and i
optimizing value in some way and trying
to figure out like can you even take a
stab at like
verbally saying what you're doing
without going into too many details and
then practicing that answer
um
probably the most tactical help i can
give there
other than zack sanchez which i really
like which would be helpful if you're if
you have to actually submit work samples
that would i think be a great play
oh thanks really thanks to you and zach
i'm starting to try to simulate where it
was a bit
tricky so i was asking here maybe you
guys could have another idea but really
thanks really thanks
yeah
and
if anyone else has ideas too feel free
to to jump in i see javier you have your
hand raised
thanks rachel
yeah i was just gonna mention um
i've been in a similar boat my whole
career and
it's very tough because a lot of what
you learn on the job
you know you want to showcase so how can
you showcase that um and like a
follow-up to zach's comment there's a
package out there called synthpop
and i'm sure there's a bunch of other
ones but synthpop
helps take your actual data points and
sort of
simulate them to make a completely
synthetic data set
um so like that's one way you could kind
of take actual distributions from your
real projects
you know create kind of a clone of it in
a way where it won't be traceable back
to the source and then
um
create a
like a web report you know a
our markdown report or a shiny app or
something around that data
um
at my last job
well i'm sorry at the job i'm currently
in now when i was interviewing for it
um
my team had been
all around data their whole careers but
not really with programmers so they were
very familiar and accustomed with like
tableau and looker
and they didn't ask me to do this but i
probably spent like four hours five
hours
on a weekend and uh built a shiny app
that i deployed for free to
shinyapps.io
um i styled the whole website or the
whole app
to have styling elements consistent with
this brand uh you know this company's
like
logo and styling so that they could kind
of see what a really clean looking shiny
app would look like
um
and like i don't attribute me getting
the job to that alone but when i showed
that to all of the interviewers they
were all like super impressed like oh my
gosh we've
did we lose javier for a second or is
that me then we lost for a second
i lost him for a minute yeah
oh you're leaving us on the
edge of our seat right now
but i
i can say i have seen that application
that javier made for that job interview
and
i thought it was an awesome example um
and i was just wondering if that's
something maybe we could as a community
help create for other people to use or
just make it like easier to show putting
in certain brand colors or logos
into an app
zach i see you had your hand raised if
you want to jump in well javier is
reconnecting yeah that's fine uh yeah so
just on the portfolio from uh
so for me of course i i'm looking to
start my career um i have so i write a
blog an nfl blog even though i'm british
uh
that's an interesting stuff but that's
another that's for another day uh so i
write all my like articles and stuff
and then on my website i have a i write
the reasons why i did it this way i
talked why i talked about this and not
this and all my ideas for it so if they
or even if say
if someone came back and went why did
you
write it in this manner or why did you
present the graph
uh
or why did you use a block box plot
instead of a bar chart or whatever just
using random examples so i could then
have a list of
where
why did each and so i think that really
helps especially when you're
so it's one of these things i actually
keep doing it as you go along it's much
easier because then i just go
this is my whole portfolio if i get when
i start looking for jobs i'll go
this is everything i've done i think
there's now
fifth year i'd say things on that now
and it just
means that they can look through what
i've done there's easy links
and yeah just makes it a lot easier for
everyone especially i like
i didn't go to university so i'm always
oh so i've already got that going
against me because everyone's just
looking for a degree so
that's why i came into the portfolio
stuff that's because i need to
especially show my skills
uh so yeah i'm happy to share my blog
and everything in my portfolio
because i think it really helped
also uh
i think rob said about looking at
linkedin i think linkedin's also another
really good place like
you can do all your features and
so people can actually see but yeah
other people are much better than this
but that's what i've just seen and copy
trial with people
that's great zach and i do see a few
people asked in the chat if you could
could share that that would be awesome
um
javier i know you
got cut off a second but we we did get
to hear about the shiny application that
you made and using their their brain
colors but
would love to
have you just continue the thought too
oh yeah i sorry i have a parrot and it's
going crazy in the background um
mainly just
you know styling a web app
with the company i was interviewing with
their entire you know logo set color
themes
um it was all controlled through
uh
like i used bslib
so i was able to
have like a custom dot s css file so
sassy you know sas css
and like
doing this kind of thing
if i was actively looking for jobs
interviewing and interviewing and
interviewing like the ability to
iterate and change out the entire theme
is so easy i mean it can be once you
have a template this can be done in like
10 minutes five minutes
so for you know anyone who's trying to
get a job and you're interviewing with a
lot of companies this could be a really
easy way for you to have something
living on
you know your personal shinyapps dot or
yeah shiny apps dot io
and whenever you
interview with a new company just like
change the link out uh change the color
theme and you could do this very quickly
and showcase that to you know your
interviewers
that's awesome thanks javier
rick i see you have your hand raised too
i'm sorry there's sirens going by
yeah i just wanted to um to mention on
that point because it's um i think i
like to think about the different ways
different disciplines think about their
work and how to present it if you've
ever worked with a designer and you get
your visual identity or you get your
brand identity or something like that
they they're they have a template and
they're just plugging
they're not creating all this up from
scratch and if you have a nicely
organized project or you have a really
really nice design pattern as a data
scientist you're showing your skills as
a software engineer or really as a
programmer so i think like if you if as
data scientists we start understanding
how designers think and how designers
work with their clients and how
software engineers and
programmers really work and organize
their projects and work as a team then
all those things kind of come in and
strengthen those and also all those
ideas are kind of tied in together
thanks rick definitely and and katie on
this topic as well i i know you speak at
a lot of meetups and like women in data
science events too and
i'd love to hear maybe more about that
if that you think that could
help people with building their
portfolio too
yeah absolutely i mean i um obviously
things have been a little different the
past two years but i think some of my
richest connections have come from
speaking
um i also think that it's just
you get it's one of those things that's
hard to to force yourself to do but you
get incrementally better at it the more
you're exposed to it um so i think it
helps you just in your job to just
present to stakeholders present to other
non-technical users um but i found it
super super um
uh kind of a creative in terms of
building up my own network but not just
in a kind of networking sense actually
people that you want to stay in touch
with you want to reach out to with you
can learn from um
so i think uh like our ladies for me is
a great starting point for that our
ladies columbus chapter is a little
slacking it's been a few um months since
a few of us had kids were a little
slower than usual but our ladies is you
know in pretty much every city and kind
of one of the one of the positives from
our current situation is that a lot of
these virtuals have a lot of these
meetups have gone virtual so it's
surprisingly easy if you don't have a
chapter in your city of our ladies or
any other meetup for you to go online
and find a meetup you can join and it's
it's been cool to see people from all
over the country come to our ladies meet
up and we've had some guest speakers
from canada that we would have never
ever been able to expose our audience to
so
um i think it's super valuable and it
should be fun if it's not fun right like
um you know then it shouldn't feel like
a pain to do it right so find the right
meetup for you
definitely and i can share in the chat
someone made a great application where
you can see like all the meetups around
the world i'll get that in just a second
but libby i i appreciate your comment in
the chat too about like convincing
ourselves to overcome imposter syndrome
to speak at meet ups is
is kind of hard sometimes and i was
curious katie if you have any tips for
that
yeah i would say start with a
comfortable one um so i know
people are pretty hesitant to speak at
our ladies meet up um and so we
try to have people who were hesitant be
then the advocates for people who are
hesitant once they've spoken so if we
have somebody who was like a little
scared to speak and then they did they
had a great experience we helped them
kind of have people shepherd people into
speaking um but it um
if you're interested we are always
looking for guest speakers at our ladies
columbus so definitely feel free to hit
me up um but i would say start with a
small group right a small comfortable
group where you know it's kind of low
pressure right so like our ladies at
least columbus is a good example of that
sometimes the presentations are just
walking through code right it doesn't
need to be super formal and it's ideal
for us to get somebody who's learning
something because often times when we
have an expert they just breeze through
a bunch of really complicated concepts
and nobody can really follow them
um but start simple keep it frequent so
toastmaster is obviously non-technical
but another way to get
you know exposure to speaking um but i
really think all speaker coaching is
that exposure effect in my opinion i
think it's just doing it um getting
feedback and
you know realizing that nothing terrible
happens even if you flub
definitely thanks katie
jaimon i appreciate that um tip in the
chat as well if you'd wanted
to jump in and say that out loud
um yeah i just wanted to recommend the
five-minute lightning talks at various
different user groups
um and i think the last one was that
even like a per package that everyone
really knows about and good tips on it
so yeah i think those are really good
opportunities to speak up and practice
your presentation skills
definitely
thank you
that's that's helped a lot for the
boston usar group too
and even as like a community organizer
if you can't find people to speak
sometimes like doing lightning talks is
really helpful
i wanted to make sure i got to some all
the anonymous questions that came in too
and i just noticed there was one
katie that was how do you feel about 100
remote versus on-site
good question um so our team's a hybrid
right now and i think that's kind of the
trickiest format and i feel like we've
we've done pretty well in terms of
making that work um
i guess is the question more about like
my preference or just managing a team
that is one or the other
um i'm not sure but i think it might be
your preference and then i would love to
hear how you you do that
with the mix of
remote yeah
um i personally love a hybrid remote
like a hybrid approach um if there are
other if there is an office to go to
um
if that makes sense so for me just the
role i'm in i feel like if there are
stakeholders meeting in person
um
i do feel like it can be a little
challenging if you're the only remote
person or if they're frequently there
now full remote i also think i could
totally adapt to if a company was full
remote right
but i do think kind of the hybrid can be
a bit tricky depending on your role we
have several individual contributor
technical roles and a lot of them are
completely remote really come to the
office and they thrive they do great
their work is you know just as impactful
as anybody else's
i think it depends on the company but if
you're in a role where your peers or
people you are serving are in person on
some cadence it can be difficult if
you're never in person that's just my
take
um in terms of how we do hybrid though i
think the key for me is like we should
never have a not non-remote friendly
event that's just not fair right um so
like we should never have like happy
hours that are in person where other
people aren't included like um team fun
happy hours those are virtual so
thanks katie and brooke i see you had
your hand raised for a question too
all right sorry that was from before i
didn't i didn't learn oh okay
no words
um just wanted to check if there are any
questions i miss from the chat feel free
to jump in and unmute yourself as well
i just had a question previously on the
hiring aspect of data for data science
role because i've been thinking about it
myself what would be the best next step
getting a master's or am a graduate
certificate in statistics versus
getting more involved into modern stacks
modern tool stacks and maybe big data
technologies and i was just curious when
we were talking about hiring process uh
what would be your um i guess preference
and i understand this on a use case
basis but be curious to hear you're
thinking about that
yeah good i mean my answer of course
would be it depends um i would say
uh
there are definitely a lot of degrees
popping up from like masters of
analytics programs masters of data
science um this is probably just a
personal preference thing but i would
probably maybe favor somebody with the
masters of applied stats over those
programs right now just based on where
our team's at so i feel like those
programs are a little broader versus
deep
and we have kind of a good set up on the
team of people with that broad exposure
to a variety of technologies i think
it's probably
from my perspective would be a miss to
hire somebody who has dabbled in like
big data platforms versus just going
after a proper data or analytics
engineer right like i'd rather hire
somebody that's deep versus somebody
who's kind of dabbled in a lot um and
i'd say my same principle probably
generally applies for statistics um
and it's very easy to have like a
cursory understanding but i think you
have a different level of training and
rigor if you've gone through more of
like a statistics focused program than
kind of the general level but that being
said there are of course people who are
fantastic fantastic in both of those
aspects deep on their own right because
they've taught themselves that right
like they're just fully capable of
learning on their own and i never rule
that out either
and i guess as a follow-up question or
the context that i wanted to add to that
um i've heard one of the opinions of a
data mentor that i respect was that
these days the depth the in-depth
knowledge of statistics may not
necessarily be relevant and the
superficial may do
especially that now you can run like a
thousand uh classification algorithm on
your laptop that would give you the you
know the response without you
necessarily knowing all the ins like
without you necessarily having an active
role into choosing which model would
perform best looking at the all of the
you know uh
performance indicators when the program
can do it for you i'm like well oh
that's a good point i honestly this is a
dilemma i found myself in when hiring i
was like i need a phd in stats and i'm
like do i do i really write like and i i
didn't i don't and we didn't get a phd
in stats we have two extremely capable
very strong data scientists both both of
them have uh masters in kind of
engineering like fields one's
bioinformatics which obviously has a
heavy statistics training um so it kind
of depends on the company for me at our
company you need to know enough to be a
informed consumer of those packages
right to not i need to trust you enough
that you know enough that you're not
gonna put something out there that is
wrong um or that i have to follow every
single detail what you're doing but that
being said there are certainly r d shops
companies where the core of their
business prop is telematics data is you
know very niche custom algorithms and
that i think is where you do need that
in-depth training so
a course kind of depends but i think
what probably is not best is if you've
had like one or two undergrad statistics
courses and you're using like this
cadillac package that allows you to do
anything you want and you really have no
idea what you're doing so that's
basically what we try to avoid in a
nutshell
thank you
thank you katie i realized once again an
hour went by very quickly um i just
wanted to check with you if there are
certain resources or like books or
podcasts that you'd recommend
to us all here that have been especially
helpful for you
oh man there was a series of videos in
our bloggers called 14 hours of machine
learning and it was the slides and
lectures from hasty and tiptorrani um
from their book like intro to ml i'm
gonna try it off i'll send it to you
afterwards they've taken down the links
to all the free videos somewhere i can't
find it anymore but i will look for that
i think that is like the best intro to
classics stats problems resampling
um i'm a big fan of all of the like our
studio articles out there so i think
like um tidy models for example that
whole suite on their website really
allows you to get up and running super
quickly um and then obviously meetups
and the proponent of those two i think
you can learn a lot so hopefully that
was a quick but informative answer but i
just love that hasty and tiptoni
resource for like the fundamentals
that's really helpful i put one into the
chat but i just googled really quickly
and didn't read it so that might not be
it but
that is but the links it was but the
links don't work so oh okay track it
down yeah well we will find it somewhere
and i'll share it in the linkedin group
as well so we also have the data science
hangout
um community linkedin group
if you want to join that i try every
week to put in a few snippets from the
conversation
um
but thank you so much katie for jumping
on and sharing your insights with us and
answering all these questions
um if people do have follow-up or want
to connect with you is twitter the best
way or linkedin what works best for you
um probably um linkedin is probably the
best source there yeah on twitter but
usually when i go to a conference not
the best twitter steward so
yeah okay same with me i'm i'm learning
to be better at twitter yeah i don't
have the skills but
i'm gonna share the the data science
hangout uh linkedin community there as
well in the chat
thank you all so much for joining have a
great rest of the day
you